don't think I've ever seen that in my
career before Alex for a guy to
intentionally kick someone in an area
that none of us want to be kicked at or
towards and for him to continue to play
I honestly don't remember the play
allegedly they were do you remember the
player where he got thrown out at the
end of the game
um yes
you know the whole game you could see
what they were doing you know just
trying to get a wise out of me I'm too
mature uh to put myself in the position
where I'm gonna get ejected unacceptable
flavoring too like the first time I was
in ejected I'm not labeled as a dirty
player and I mean I didn't hit him in a
private area
um or somebody draped on you like that
defensively it's just a natural
basketball reaction and I didn't I
didn't hit him enough hard enough
fall down like that honestly I don't
even think it was a problem but
um
wow what do you think he's 100 correct
if they didn't kick Joelle out they
shouldn't have kicked him out uh uh I I
don't know what the hell going on to be
honest with you uh I just I had a
problem
I did I have a problem you you try to
you try to kick a guy
and then you accidentally because I
don't think he intentionally hit that
dude but you have a guy trying to kick a
guy come on man I have a problem with
this with this
I mean that's that's a dirty play right
there Ernie and then to and and
if you're gonna let Joelle spin the game
you can't kick James out for something
that's that's simple
Kenny weigh in
well I think the two incidents are
individual I don't think they that they
run connected they aren't connected and
there has to be some rule that dictates
below the belt or above the head I know
there's one below that above the head
of the neck
that is an automatic uh flagrant too uh
but I'm not sure about the second one so
it had to be something that to that
effect you sure about the person
yeah I thought that was a flagrant one
flagrant one yes
which is so you agreed with the you
agreed with the call First my first
reaction was flagrant one I mean it
looked taste off
again if collecting don't step over them
Joe's not that type of player but he
reacted he kicked it I thought it was
flagrant too I thought he should have
been a jacket the second one
is what's known as incidental contact
every guard in the game now uses that
offhand to try to gain a better position
than James Harden been doing that for
years trying to draw a contact and he
accidentally
incidentally hit the man above his
private part so I don't think he should
have been thrown out you know the one
thing that as a player you just want
consistency and there's no way
there's no way if you got any common
sense you can look at that one play and
look at that other Play Because Joelle
what he did was way worse than what
James did yeah you know I think the
League's antenna are up in this week
especially in with the intensity of
playoff basketball and with what
happened with the Draymond Green
situation I think the officials antenna
are up they're looking
really closely at a lot of this stuff
and if and if that play the hardened
play is as common as you make it seem or
if that's incidental contact happens a
lot I mean what happens
Friday or Saturday a similar play
happens and now you set this precedent
if you say hey James Harden got kicked
out of the game for that same thing I
don't I mean it's uh it's going to be
interesting to watch this watch this
thing play out but tonight Philadelphia
taking a three-nothing lead over
Brooklyn 102 to 97 is your final score
game